- Thanks to the first two speakers
and now our third speaker on the panel
is Doctor Yvonne Bonnie Maldonado,
who is Professor of the
departments of Pediatrics
and Health Research and Policy,
Chief of Division of Infectious Diseases
and Senior Associate Dean
of Faculty Development
and Diversity at Stanford
University School of Medicine,
down the road from here.
And Doctor Maldonado's research interests
are the epidemiology and prevention
of viral vaccine preventable diseases
such as measles, polio, rotavirus.
And she is internationally
known and published
in Zimbabwe, in Mexico,
and in the United States.
A fellow of the American
Academy of Pediatrics
and the Infectious Disease
Society of America.
And on and on and on and on.
And we are privileged to have you join us
for this discussion of
Zika, thank you Bonnie.
(applause)
- Thank you Lucy sorry you were so so busy
I didn't get a chance to.
Thank you everybody and
hopefully I'll be able
to keep you awake after lunch.
Thank you for inviting me.
We are all colleagues even
though we are right down
the street we are not, we're
all trying to get along,
so I always am happy to be at UCSF
and represent my colleagues here.
Because we're all in this together,
especially for a disease like this
that as you've heard already
we don't know much about
and we need to work together
to figure out what to do.
So I have no disclosures for this.
I am on an advisory board, data
safety and monitoring board
for a vaccine trial by Pfizer.
I'm also by the way on
the red book committee
for the American Academy of Pediatrics,
I'm the vice chair of that committee,
I'm also the AAP representative
on the Zika CDC guidelines.
So I can maybe explain
a little bit more about
what they mean by consider
which means they don't know.
(laughter)
So yeah they don't know but they also
don't wanna discourage people
from not doing anything
so they just say well if
we say MRI then they won't
do anything so maybe we'll
just say if you want to,
go ahead and do it but
don't let that stop you
from doing all the other stuff.
So I think they're really
worried about people.
In fact about 25% of
practices aren't doing any
of the evaluations that
we're recommending.
Because they don't, we
know why but they're just
not doing them, so.
Anyway you saw this wonderful slide.
Actually it's not true
that other viral diseases
transmitted by mosquitoes
have caused this.
We have seen for example
chikungunya, dengue,
and others have actually
caused congenital malformations
of the brain so they're not very common.
And that's what's very
striking about Zika,
is that it does cause a
very substantial proportion
at this time.
Now remember we're looking
at a very early onset
of a virus that came into a population
that was completely susceptible
with lots of crowding et cetera.
And so we don't really know
if this is gonna continue
to be a pattern or if this
is really just hitting
all of the susceptible
populations all at one time
and maybe we'll see it slow down.
So right now we're in a slow
period all around the world.
Especially in tropical
areas where right now
they are not yet in the rainy season.
They're gonna start coming
back into the rainy season.
I was just in the Yucatan Peninsula
and also in Puerto Rico
talking about cases
and it's been very quiet
right now but we're heading
into the rainy season.
So we don't know whether this,
cause this is the first year
we really are looking at this
and we won't know what's gonna happen.
You already saw most of these case counts
are a little bit more up to
date but only a weeks more.
I think the important
thing here to remember
is you need to know the local transmission
even if you don't have any.
But also be aware of transmission
because there are a lot
of people who travel.
About 40 million people
a year go to places
where there might be Zika transmission
or where there's definitely mosquitoes.
So you will actually start seeing people
who have traveled to areas
and may be concerned.
So these are the numbers
that you've already seen.
It's really important to note
here that there are a lot
of cases in the Caribbean.
Over almost 40000 cases
now locally acquired.
It's really hard to look
at sexual transmission
in an area where there's
so much local transmission.
So we really don't know the impact there.
When you look at aggregate
cases in pregnant women
as you heard is about
almost 1400 in the US
and the District of Columbia.
About 3000 in Puerto Rico
and they keep their own
separate data so their
numbers vary depending
on who you ask in Puerto Rico.
But they're certainly
seeing a lot of cases there.
Now in the US and the
District of Columbia,
we have about 1000 completed pregnancies
with 38 liveborns with birth defects
and five pregnancy losses that
we know with birth defects.
Not all of these have been
confirmed to be Zika though
around the losses.
And in the US territories
the Puerto Rican data's
not available online
but when I was talking
to a health department there
they said that they'd had
about 50 pregnancy loses
but they didn't actually
look for Zika in all of them
so we don't know that those
are related to Zika.
And about five children who
were born with birth defects.
The virus again as you heard about
was identified in 1947
but what's really striking
is that it really just took
off when it came to Brazil.
It's been circulating for many many years,
primarily in central Africa.
And then in the early
2000s it started migrating
into Asia and Southeast Asia,
primarily because of infected individuals
coming into countries and then
infecting local mosquitoes.
So there is that cycle there.
We do have that opportunity unfortunately
here in the southern part of the US.
But not as high as the risks in Brazil
or other places in the world because
we have better screening
and air conditioning.
It is a virus that's related
to yellow fever and dengue
which actually is endemic
now in the Caribbean
and parts of northern Latin
American and it's a flavivirus.
These viruses are
arboviruses which stands for
arthropod-borne viruses
or mosquito borne viruses.
They're usually transmitted primarily
by the bite of an infected arthropod.
It's the Aedes species in
this situation, Aedes aegypti
and Aedes albopictus is
the secondary vector.
Ticks obviously no transmission for Zika
but for the other arbos it can be.
And there can be a cycle
primarily of just mosquito
to human to mosquito.
But as you know we also have
transmission in other routes
as we'll talk about.
So these are the two culprits.
Here this is Aedes aegypti up here.
This is the most common vector for Zika.
This is Aedes albopictus
which also can transmit.
We don't have a lot of
these mosquitoes in the US
but they can be imported in
cargo containers et cetera
that have small bits of
water where larvae can grow.
They can also transmit dengue
and chikungunya viruses
which are also prevalent now
in the Caribbean as well.
And these are nervous feeders.
That is as opposed to Anopheles mosquitoes
which transmit malaria and
only bite one person at a time
and then move off.
Aedes are very nervous biters.
They'll bite and feed for a little bit
and then they'll jump around.
So they can feed on up to
five to 10 people a day
so the risk of transmission
from multiple people
is much higher.
As you heard before there are
other modes of transmission,
sexual, mother to fetus,
and possibly breast milk,
blood transfusion, lab
exposure and organ transplant
also are theoretical.
The question around sexual
transmission's not clear yet
because again in the areas
where there's most Zika,
it's hard to detect the difference between
sexual transmission and locally
acquired from mosquitoes.
In the US we have seen cases as you know.
And this is just a schematic showing you
that we have an infected person here,
they can transmit to a mosquito,
and then the mosquito
can live in households.
And by the way these
mosquitoes love biting humans
as opposed to the Anopheles
which transmit malaria
which prefer to bite large animals,
not that we're not large, but
big and like cows and horses
and that kind of thing.
Aedes love biting humans and
so they love to live inside
houses and they can live in
up to a teaspoon of water.
So doesn't take a lot of
liquid for them to grow.
And then you can see the cycle here.
But again we talked about
mother to child transmission,
sexual transmission and
other blood borne methods
of transmission.
Where is Zika now?
It's reported in 70 countries
now and here's a list.
Just looking at the western hemisphere
you can see the western
hemisphere is quite impacted.
You notice that Chile doesn't
seem to have any cases
and it may be that with the Andes there,
they may not have as
many cases or any cases
that have been reported to date.
Now what about in the US?
Zika has been reported in 49 states
and the District oF Columbia.
The one state that has not
reported Zika cases is Alaska.
There has been local
transmission in Florida
and in the very very southern
tip of Texas as well.
And we've seen it in
American Samoa, Puerto Rico,
as I mentioned which is really accounts
for most of the transmissions
so far in the US territories
and of US Virgin Islands as well.
We talked about symptoms already.
I think what's really
important to point out here
from the epidemiologic
perspective is that 80% of people
are not symptomatic.
Even when you look going forward,
you do not see evidence of symptoms.
So you could have silent
transmission and circulation
of this virus and not
know what's going on.
So this is what worries
us in particular around
a pregnancy.
We had talked about congenital disease.
This is just a schematic
showing that you really do have
a drop out of neuronal cells.
And this really is very
much in parallel to rubella,
which really does kill these cells.
And if you take these
cells in tissue culture
and you grow them, they will just die.
They completely just get devastated.
And we know that the Zika receptor,
and that stated from the ECSF
actually was the first report
and then some from Hopkins later,
demonstrated that the Zika
receptor exists in many
of the neural progenitor cells,
that is the cells that
become the brain later on.
But also all over the placenta.
Both on the maternal
side and the fetal side.
So there's lots of opportunities
for this virus to infect.
CDC and other labs confirmed
Zika in fetal tissues.
And theses are pictures showing
evidence of Zika virus here,
products of fetal demise.
And also has been identified
in amniotic fluid, placenta,
the brain and other
products of conception.
You heard a little bit about
the evidence of causality
but there is very very rigorous
data now coming from CDC
and others looking at many
not only just the evidence
of teratogenicity but also
causality for microcephaly.
And both of those Shepherds criteria,
the Bradford Hill criteria,
which are the classic
epidemiological criteria
to establish causality have been met.
It was in very short period of time
people have really
looked at this carefully
and this is a paper summarizing that.
I would encourage people
who are interested
to look at the CDC.govt/Zika website
and you can find anything you need to know
including resources and we'll
talk about that in a bit.
But this study also, as you heard earlier,
emphasizes the fact that even children,
so we don't think that
Zika is a latent virus,
that means we don't think it incorporates
into the human genome and stays forever.
But we do think that it can hide.
But we don't know how long
it can hide in the body.
We do know that it can
stay in semen for example
for several months.
It can be in the cervical
secretions of pregnant women
for many many weeks.
And we don't know how long that can be.
So we do think at some point
the virus does get killed.
We also think that
immunity could be lifelong
if we think about it from the standpoint
of other flaviviruses.
But the important thing is that
when a child looks asymptomatic at birth,
it doesn't mean they're not infected,
and that that infection may not set up
long term complications.
Oh I'm going the wrong way sorry.
So this is a study that
is really not based
on actual transmission data in patients.
This is really looking at an
aggregate of what's happened
so far primarily in Bahia,
Brazil which is where
the original outbreak was
thought to have started
in the western hemisphere, the big one.
And it is estimated
that between one and 13%
of Zika infections can
lead to microcephaly.
And it's thought also from this model
that it's most likely to
occur in the first trimester
but we don't know that for sure.
And you heard about Zika in pregnancy.
One of the important
things to note is that
it's not worse in women who are pregnant.
We don't think that they're at
higher risk for bad symptoms
or for prolonged, well maybe
prolonged transmission,
because as we know we just
found out that there can be
prolonged shedding in the
cervical and vaginal tracts.
So there may be increased
shedding of the virus.
And transmission through breast milk
has not been documented
but it has been found
in samples of breast milk.
And we know about the
clinical manifestations
around neurologic disease.
So severe microcephaly and
also I would like to point out
that some of the peripheral findings
at this point appear to be related
to actual direct infection
of the spinal cord,
or effect of the spinal cord not just
the central nervous system.
So you're not only having CNS
disease but also peripheral.
And in that case that
may account for some of
the contractions that we're seeing
but we don't know that for sure yet.
There are post natal
infections in children.
And it's important to point
out that in these post natal
infections the children
actually just get symptoms
that are similar to those
in adults and older children
and appears to be mild and
does not seem to be associated
with any of the severe outcomes
that we see in children
who have transmission
from mother to child.
And the question is at
what point after birth
do you have this relatively mild course
compared to the severe ones.
So for example if you're exposed
during breast feeding only
or if you're exposed during
the labor and delivery process
will that always lead to just
mild infection or no infection?
And we don't know that either.
So who should be tested?
I think you heard all of
the guidelines already.
Patients obviously with symptoms
who have been in areas where we know that
Zika transmission is occurring.
Or who have been linked
epidemiologically to a case.
Or other people who are asymptomatic
who've traveled to these areas or who have
a sexual partner at risk.
It is nationally notifiable as you heard
as well as congenital infections.
And infants should be tested for Zika
if they have microcephaly or
intracranial calcifications
and were born to women
who traveled to or resided
in areas with Zika
transmission while pregnant.
Or born to mothers with
positive or inconclusive testing
especially with the IGM
test for Zika infection.
Communicating test results,
I think you already heard about this.
It's really important to get
the data to the local or state
health department because
there are a number of national
and international registries
'cause we're trying
to figure out how to aggregate these
and figure out what the natural history
of the disease would be.
There is no specific
treatment and you're gonna get
the usual kind of advice
around getting plenty of rest
and drinking fluids to
prevent dehydration et cetera.
But really nothing specific
about this disease.
There are vaccines that are in the process
of being developed and
the assistant secretary
for preparedness and response
for the federal government
as well as another
organization called BARDA
which also develops interventions
for the Department of Defense,
are working on a number of vaccines.
And there are quite a few.
And they are looking at
potential general use
and commercial distribution by 2020
which I think is very optimistic.
But they are starting to look
at doing some early studies
and at least in primates
of candidate Zika vaccines
appeared to be pretty
effective in preventing
not only disease but even
the spread of virus and blood
in other body fluids.
And so here's a landscape
of Zika vaccine development.
And the further to the left you see
the more early in stages are the vaccines.
So there are two vaccines, two or three,
I think it's two vaccines
now that are ready
for human clinical trials.
And we're looking forward
to seeing the results
of those trials coming up soon.
So we don't know a lot.
And what don't we know?
We don't know if there's a
safe time during your pregnancy
to travel to an area with Zika.
If a person travels and gets bitten,
how likely are you to get Zika?
Or that your baby will have birth defects
from the infection.
Trimester of pregnancy
appears that earlier
is more important but we have seen babies
who we think have been
exposed during later trimester
and can be affected as well.
And we don't know if previous infections
provide immunity or
whether previous infections
will have an impact on future pregnancies.
I won't go thought the evaluation
and outpatient management.
I just wanted you to see
that there is an algorithm
as was pointed out earlier
that the CDC will provide
and it's in your booklet.
If you really really need to do that,
you should probably really
talk to a specialist
who can help you because it's
really multidisciplinary,
involving neurologists,
ophthalmologists, et cetera,
many other people.
We really need to make
a very clear statement
around family and psychosocial support.
And there are a number of
resources at the CDC website
where you can look at
information for families
when you're communicating the disease.
There are pediatric
evaluation and follow up tools
as well at the CDC
website which you can use
for management.
There are a number of
studies as you can imagine
that are being done now.
The main questions are
what is the level of risk
during pregnancy?
When during pregnancy is
the risk at highest peak?
What is the full range of
health effects on babies?
Is there mild neurologic
disease or severe?
And I'm sure there is but
how to we determine that?
And what other infections?
For example in these areas that have Zika,
they already had dengue virus
which is a related disease.
And there's lab based
evidence that when you have
antibody to dengue it might
actually make the Zika virus
infection worse.
But we only know that because
of lab studies using cells.
So if you grow cells and
you put Zika virus in them,
and you add antibody to dengue,
the cells get more infected,
and they get more disrupted.
But we don't know if
that's true in humans yet.
So in some studies have suggested that
that may not be true in humans.
So that would just be
a horrible thing for us
and we would really need to
ramp up our prevention efforts.
Not that we shouldn't do
it anyway but that would be
important to know.
And then of course all of
the late onset problems
that we might see as well.
There are a number of
pregnancy registries.
There's the CDC pregnancy registry,
the Zika active pregnancy
surveillance system
in Puerto Rico,
there's one in Columbia.
There's birth defects surveillance here
and then there's an Arbonet surveillance
of children with Zika.
So quite a number and last
week one of my faculty members
who works on Zika in Grenada
went to a World Health
Organization meeting
where they have every
organization they could think of
who had children that they were following
because they really are
trying to get this data
together as quickly as possible.
So I will just say that what
you can really do at this point
is report cases if you
suspect them to the registry.
And also to really take advantage
of all of the resources to
get more educated about this
in case you find children
who might have evidence
of microcephaly or if a pregnant woman
has been at risk of traveling.
So know the basics.
Diagnose and test if you can,
and if you don't have
that capacity yourself,
know who you can refer to.
Understand the assessment and management
should you come upon it.
Many many of these academic
centers will have that
capability to help you out.
And really what you can
do on an individual level
is provide support in
your respective fields
for these families.
And inform your state and local
health department as well.
So these are my references
and I will stop there.
And thank you so much for your attention.
(applause)